un respiro al menos temporal para el
presidente de perú al no aceptar la
renuncia del primer ministro aníbal
torres el presidente pedro castillo
esquiva un nuevo voto de confianza del
congreso torres alegó motivos personales
para poner a disposición su cargo si la
renuncia del premier hubiese sido
aceptada habría sido el cuarto primer
ministro en abandonar el puesto en 13
meses de gobierno de castillo sin
embargo hubo un importante movimiento en
el gabinete como nuevas incorporaciones
destacan miguel rodríguez como canciller
kurt burneo ex ministro en el gobierno
de ollanta humala en el ministerio de
economía
betsy chávez en la cartera de cultura y
césar paniagua quien jura como encargado
del ministerio de vivienda construcción
y saneamiento otros simplemente se
mudaron de oficina alejandro salas quien
deja el ministerio de cultura y pasa al
trabajo y gamer alvarado quien deja el
ministerio del trabajo y asume como
ministro del transporte y comunicaciones
la oposición arremetió con críticas nos
sumió en una nueva crisis con la
renuncia de torres para complicarnos más
con sus designados pobre perú
y la agenda de trabajo continúa sin
contratiempos el dignatario se mostró
este fin de semana junto a su jefe de
gabinete en medio de las denuncias de
corrupción que caen sobre castillo las
relaciones del mandatario con el
congreso no pasa por su mejor momento en
una decisión sin precedentes el
hemiciclo decidió no otorgar permiso al
jefe de estado para participar esta
semana en la toma de posición del nuevo
presidente colombiano actualmente son
cinco las investigaciones penales
abiertas contra castillo mientras se
suman los llamados a un juicio político